Since I've gotten older,
skincare has become a much bigger part of my routine
and definitely helps maintenance,
definitely helps makeup go on better.
Um, so I wanna show you a couple of the things,
especially for anti aging, or at least with, like,
my skin is starting to get a little bit older.
I'm 36, um,
so I'm not, you know,
at mature skin yet,
but I'm starting to notice extra dryness,
fine lines, um,
and just some things that I want to shift in my skincare
to keep up with the growth and changing of my skin.
So I'm fresh faced right out of the shower.
I'm gonna start with a rosewater facial toner.
I've. This one's actually from Trader Joe's, and I just soak it in.
I've noticed that anything with rose oil or rose water
is super hydrating,
and my skin just, like,
soaks it up. It loves it.
I then go in with a collagen serum.
This one's from dupology.
I just started using it.
It is incredible for, like,
plumping and hydrating,
and you want this to be fully dry before adding thing else.
So during the day,
I'll just use the deepology serum
and then move on to the rest of my skincare,
which I'm about to do.
But at night, you can use these patches
that you go and put on to target fine lines and wrinkles or dry spots.
I wear them overnight.
I get really,
really dry patches in my Skin, especially, like, up around my eye area,
and they're perfect for that.
I then go in for daytime with a vitamin C.
This one's from typology.
I really like it.
Let that dry and absorb,
and then I'll go in with my park Perfection Eye Cream.
It's kind of hard to say park perfection.
Um, this is the holy grail for me.
It's a small family owned business.
It literally. You can watch your eyes change if you are extra baggy.
I then going with a moisturizer and then followed up with SPF.
I really like this one from Willetta.
Um, it is light but super hydrating,
which again, my skin is getting a little bit extra dry.
We need. We need something serious.
I then use the Supergoops Unseen Sunscreen as my base,
like primer before makeup,
and that's daytime skincare.
I will then go into makeup.